hello everyone and welcome to day one of
the grand chester in paris
it's the rapid event first we're gonna
have three days of rapid and then two
days of blitz
uh in the rapid event the time control
is 25 minutes for all moves and
for every move starting from move one we
have a 10 second delay
and then uh after three days of rapid we
have two days of blitz like we said and
then uh you will have
18 rounds of blitz with uh five minutes
plus three seconds
delay uh so that's about the time
control here we have a wonderful game
from round three young shisht of duda
versus alexander grishock
uh really an insane game but before we
check it out
uh we do have uh one nice photo i want
you to see
uh courtesy of leonard otis official
photographer of the grand chester
and this really raises the bar in chess
photography
this uh i hope i hope you're ready for
it uh here it is
uh shakira mamidarov and maxine vashir
lagrav enjoying
a nice swing there you can see they are
they're both very happy
and regardless of how they play here in
paris with this attitude
they are already winners uh so there you
have it i do hope you enjoyed that
uh in the description below as usual you
can check out some of leonard's other
work i will put a link to his twitter
and instagram uh
profile in the description below so feel
free to check out his other work
now getting back to the game uh duda
opens with the white pieces and he plays
f3
we have d5 by grishouk c4
and now d4 just grabbing more space in
the center and
we have b4 by white white does the same
and now controls uh
well a lot of squares on the queen side
with f6 by black
this is the main line uh preparing to
push e5
very rare that you will have an f6 in
the opening uh e3 and now
e5s planned and now white pushes c5 so
this is uh
all very nice preparation with a5
challenging the flank here uh and queen
to a4 check and here you can choose
if you want to block with the bishop if
you want to block with the queen you
could also block with the knight but
that's very rarely played so if you play
bishop blocks then you can even play
something like b5 but here we have queen
blocks and
here duda plays bishop to b5 now of
course
attacking the queen so c6 you have to
play this bishop back to c4 and now
knight to a6 preparing to capture on b4
and here
duda goes uh uh e captures on d4
uh grisha pushes the pawn with e4
challenging the knight
and now just b5 challenging the knight
here on a6
uh with knight to b4 and now a3
challenging the knight once again so
here we have a trade
e captures on f3 with a captures on b4
and now queen captures on d4
so what you play here d3 this is uh
the way this line is played and how you
will allow queen e5 check and a capture
on g2
so this is all home preparation from
duda queen e5
check with bishop to e3 and now pawn
captures on g2
uh threatening to win the rook rook to
g1 and this is where the game
really begins because all of this has
been played before uh there is
one game uh played in 2013 2014 he was
played
in the tournament over over new year in
the denmark team championship
uh tiger hiller person versus uh johnny
hector
uh played queen captures on h2 here and
of course white won a very nice game
now white played a bit differently but
probably duda prepared
the the correct line here after queen
captures on h2 yes you are threatening
to capture the rook but here
white just ignores you uh white will
just play king to d2
allow you to capture the rook and after
queen captures here
b captures on c6 now threatening to
capture here with
check grab another queen uh and after
black uh
well prevents this king to d8 now you
play knights the c3
you threaten the queen and after queen
to h2 preparing to queen the pawn now
you play knight to d5
with a terrible threat and here
basically whatever black plays black
will lose
if you just play uh pawn to g1 queen
uh you can just play rook captures on g1
uh just to get
uh the queen's defense of the c7 square
eliminated and after queen captures you
can just play c7 mate
uh this is just insane knight covers e7
the queen covers this diagonal
uh this is just beautiful and of course
the knight guards the pawn here
so it is uh not possible to capture the
pawn here
and grishok did not know this the grisha
had to calculate a lot here
uh because duda didn't waste any time
getting to this position
he just blitzed out all of the moves and
grishok spent a lot
a lot of time and since you only have 25
minutes you don't really
get to spend all that much time so
grisha played knight to e7 he said okay
i'm not touching that pawn i mean if you
played it all the way here and you're
allowing it
uh probably angry shook thought he
doesn't even need to calculate it to
know it's bad for him but
you can't just trust your opponent i
mean you don't get to be
20 27 and 50 plus a grand master by
trusting your opponents
but okay here duda also uh doesn't
doesn't bother himself with the g21 he
just continues knight to d2
continues developing and again here you
can capture on h2 but now okay knight f3
guards the rook kicks away the queen
queen h5 and now
knights the d4 puts more pressure here
so you don't really want to do this
especially if you're running into
preparation like grishok is doing here
so after knight d2 we have bishop to d7
by grishok and now
b captures an a5 uh and here
knight to d5 by grishok knight to f5
would have been a little bit better
because it prevents
duda's idea here duda goes d4 attacks
the queen
if the knight was serious you would be
able to just capture the d4 pawn but
okay then dude i would play something
else uh queen captures on h2 now
you have to play it uh as you have to
move the queen either way and the white
doesn't really have a good way to punish
you so why not
knight f3 defends the rook attacks the
queen queen to h5
and now even a6 uh here dude's plan is
to just capture on b7
uh give up the queen and you don't
really give up the queen since you're
gonna get another one and then you're
gonna recapture the rook
so what do you do here uh question is
can grisha capture the knight not really
if you capture the knight you get a
captures on b7 like we said
this doesn't do anything you just uh
grab another queen and then recapture
the rook
so probably rook b8 and then you play b
captures on c6
and now well knight captures on e3 you
can play this
but then c7 again you tried to give up
the queen
but now you have two connected past
pawns on the seventh rank black is dead
lost here
for example queen captures on b7 you can
play something like that but it just
captures on b8 with
check queen captures and now queen to a8
uh
white is uh uh with with the two
connected past pawns is
in a much better position check king d2
now you have to trade here and after you
move the king
now even d5 threatening d6 mate
as the bishop covers all all of the
squares here and the rook covers squares
here
so white can even play in in such a
great style and whatever black plays now
you capture the knight and now you're
just
well better here uh so uh
bishop to e7 by grishok not uh caring
about the knight and f3 and now
duda continues with his plan a captures
on b7
uh rook captures on a4 rook captures on
a4
and now grishok castles and here we have
rook to a8
just uh hoping to grab that rook and
promote the spawn into a queen
so what could you play here well
probably best with c captures on b5 but
then you get rook captures on f8
bishop captures on f8 you get another
queen into the game and then
b captures on c4 you grab another bishop
and now it's uh uh hard to play this uh
i mean you know
black would win this game there's uh not
all that much you can do here
uh the c the past t point is very strong
you'd probably have to
go back defend the knight on f3 and then
uh it's just gonna be a terrible game
for white
so uh grishok uh doesn't go with
that idea which was probably the the
best way to go he goes to rook to e8 but
okay he wants the queen to be able to
recapture
so uh white doesn't have a defender
of the b8 square when he wants to grab
another queen uh we have
king to d2 and now uh grishok again
probably g5 uh and then after rook
captures and g2 kg7 just getting the
kick out of the back rank
uh but still uh it's a tough position
for grishok he's very low on time and
well he's uh he you you still feel that
you
ran into preparation and you have to you
know create something
uh but here instead of that grisha
played king to f8 which
does not work so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out
why it doesn't work uh well i'll give
you a couple of seconds
uh for those of you who were able to do
it uh congratulations
you have just found a a brilliant line
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
you have to find bishop to f4 but not
now first
first you capture uh the rook and then
uh if bishop captures
it then you just get a queen into the
game it's not really something you want
to do
queen here and then after queen captures
here now you go queen g3
queen captures f captures and after
captures captures you will get c
captures on b5 but now
bishop to d5 and here it's a bishop and
rook against two bishops so while the
bishop pair is very nice uh the bishop
and rook will be will be stronger for
example f5 you're going to capture
on g2 so you're going to get rid of this
one and at the end of the day you have
two connected past pawns
so not happening so uh agriculture of
course went with queen captures on e8
and now comes
bishop captures on d5 removing the
defender of the f4
square and now it's all over there's no
defense against this if you captured
upon
bishop f4 regards the queening square
you're just going to queen that pawn
this is why i said
uh if you found bishop to f4 then you
easily found rook captures and
bishop captures on d5 so grisham played
bishop to d8 here
but it's uh the same doesn't really work
uh
the idea is i mean there is a trick now
if
duda promotes to a queen then you get
bishop a5 check and then you just pick
up the queen black
black wins the game but dude of course
is not uh tricked easily he just played
the bishop to f4
controls the b8 square uh we have bishop
to a5 checked by grishok but
king to d1 and it was in this position
uh that alexander grishok resigned the
game as
there is nothing more to do here
whatever you play next move you get a
queen into the game
and it's all over c captures b8 queen
and white is just up too much material
queen captures bishop captures and as
you can see
black has two bishops and white has two
bishops but also a knight in the rook
which is very nice
uh so yeah after this uh king the d1
grisham resigned the game and a
brilliant victory for yanchus of duda
uh i will not mention uh the standings
as i
i'm planning to show another game
tomorrow morning so we're gonna check
out the standings then
so really uh an impressive game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank carson carso donald hughes uh
jimmy hernandez borislav milanovic and
clark archer for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it and congratulations mr
clark archer who decided to return to
competitive chess at the age of 49
uh so congratulations on your decision
sir and you know
don't forget to brush up on that end
game
so yeah uh i really really hope you
enjoyed it and for the end of this video
maybe
uh check out this nice photo again just
look at those two that's
uh that's uh looks like a lot of fun
uh so uh as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the well the short
coverage of the
grand chester in paris continuing the
copa blanca saga and as usual checking
up on your suggestions
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your saturday